near Alta Badia in the Italian Dolomites
a legacy of horrendous violence has left
behind a kind of gift it's a museum in
the mountains I am very much not a
mountain climber but when I visited
ultimate eeeh in 2014 I got to pretend
for the day I was able to look up at
this towering spire of rock I said to
myself you know what I just don't like
climb that mountain by clipping a
carabiner to a metal cable and pulling
myself up a series of iron runs I was
able to climb a mountain that I would
never normally have been able to and it
was really amazing
but these beautiful vistas were once the
site of massive violence made possible
by these iron rungs and cables that I
was climbing this system was known as
the via ferrata where the iron italy
declared war on the austro-hungarian
Empire in May 1915 and soldiers rushed
up both sides of the mountains they
began fighting at the top of these snowy
icy impasses and this became known as
the dolomite front or the white war
these soldiers fought at altitudes of up
to 12,000 feet and in weather as cold as
negative 22 degrees Fahrenheit digging
in for a long fight the Austrians built
an entire ice city on the side of the
mountain they had storerooms and
barracks and everything was connected by
ice tunnels and both sides built
incredibly elaborate systems of cabling
and iron rungs to bring both soldiers
and supplies up and down the mountain
who is this system these via ferrata or
iron roads that made this insane fight
even possible
both the Italians in the Austrians
tunnel the idea was to tunnel as close
beneath an enemy bunker pack them with
explosives and then blow the opposing
force off mountain in early 1916 the
Italians decided to strike a decisive
blow at the Austrians and they spent
three months digging a tunnel that would
come just 12 feet below the Austrian
bunker
hands could hear them digging for weeks
but were told to hold position on April
14th the noise stopped and a hundred men
were instantaneously vaporized as were
90 feet off the top of the mountain by
the time the goal of my front was
abandoned in 1917 a hundred and fifty
thousand men had died on the mountains
mostly of cold and exposure today the
remains of this war are ever-present you
can visit the bunkers and tunnels carved
by these soldiers and climb the same via
ferrata routes that they climbed to
bring supplies up and down the last few
decades over 80 soldiers have been
recovered as the ice has thawed and
released their bodies I climbed peach'
du which is a newer route but there are
over 400 via ferrata in the area it's a
chance both to look at the incredible
natural beauty and mourn those lost on
the mountainside subscribe here and
watch more videos here for me personally
it was a real victory to climb up that
mountain through the via ferrata I'd
always thought of myself as more of a
sedimentary type geology jokes